>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Kevin Merida.
>> Kevin Merida: Good afternoon.
We have quite a treat.
We have Kareem Abdul-Jabbar with us.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
So as you know it's a cliché
but he really is somebody
who needs no introduction.
He is the NBA's all
time leading scorer
and a Basketball Hall
of Fame Inductee.
Well since retiring after 20 years
in NBA he has been an accurate
basketball coach and the author
of 11 books, many of them
New York Times Bestsellers.
We're here today to talk
about "Writings on the Wall,
Searching for a New
Equality beyond Black
and White" which is his latest.
Kareem also is a columnist for
Time and The Washington Post,
where I work for 22 years, writing
on a range of topics including race
and politics, age and pop culture.
In 2012, he was selected as
the US Cultural Ambassador.
But I kind of come
to look at him now
as really quite the public
intellectual, a brilliant man
with brilliant insights
on these times.
In 2004, I was still
at the Washington Post
and I'll just tell
you a brief story.
Right now, I am editor-in-chief
of the undefeated ESPN's new--
relatively new digital platform that
focuses on race, sports and culture.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
When I was working on a book in 2004
and Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas and I went
to the NBA All-Star Game in Los
Angeles and I wanted to get athletes
with cultural insights, thinking
that that might add a
dimension to the book.
I came up with just Kareem, I
didn't have any schedule interview
and I asked him about
Justice Thomas.
And no offense to athletes
in general,
but I wasn't expecting this
really cogent assessment.
There was a Leon Higginbotham
is the late federal judge
and he had written this really
tough critic of Justice Thomas
that had been circulating in
among law students and as one
of my lawyer friend said it was like
fire on the wild prairie catching on
and burning and people
were talking it.
And here was Kareem who knew about
that and he gave quite a critic
which include-- was included
in my book and, you know,
I left that All-Star game thinking
that this was a really
well read man.
I'm really proud to be here
and to have this conversation
with Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
and let's get going.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> How you doing?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: I'm
doing very well, thank you.
>> Kevin Merida: Thank you.
So this book, "Writings on the
Wall", why this book and why now?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well,
this book is basically my take
on what's going on in
our country right now.
We're going through a very
divisive time in our republic
and it concerns me because it seems
like Americans are not talking
to each other, they're talking past
each other, and that's not part
in our tradition and it's not
very healthy for our nation.
So I am very concerned about
that and I decided to put pen
to paper and talk about it.
>> Kevin Merida: You
writing the book that a lot
of the world's misery
can be attributed
to people being ill-informed,
uninformed, misinformed.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
Well absolutely.
People who have problems
to solve really need
to know what the facts are, right?
When you don't take the
time to equip yourself
with what is actually going on,
not what people's opinions are
but what actually are the
facts, when you're not
in fact racist it's hard to
find your way out of the woods.
You really keep running into
misinterpretations of things
and situations that
have to be dealt with
and it makes it very
difficult to get anything done.
>> Kevin Merida: But we're
at the National Book Festival
so we know there are
lots of readers here.
I know you mentioned that, you know,
you read all the time, you know.
You would read, you know, when
you were a high school athlete
and college athlete and pro-athlete,
leaving games on planes,
reading books, is that kind of
the foundation of, you know,
that that something is missing
you think in this country?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: I think
even people who don't have the time
to read can be informed
just by turning on the TV
and making sure they look at
a couple of news broadcast
and get a few different
takes on what's going
on with the current events.
And that really should
prompt people to do
like a little bit more in-depth--
ask a few more in-depth questions
about what's going on and
why and it enables them
to figure what their take
on the solution should be.
But people who don't
know what's going on
and who can't really describe
how things are affecting America,
it's impossible for
them to contribute.
>> Kevin Merida: So
we're in the final months
of this historic presidency,
the first African-American
to be president of this
country, Barack Obama.
You talked about something
you called the Obama Effect,
maybe explain that?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well,
what I could call the
Obama Effect is the fact
that when President Obama
was elected, people thought
that that was the end of
racism in America, after all,
we picked our chief executive,
the person who is our leader.
We picked an African-American
and people thought that,
geez that means that racism is over.
And it was a significant
milepost but it is--
was not a sign that said
that we've reached the end
of the road and racism is over.
We still have a lot of work to do.
Do check out what Dr. King
said about looking forward,
some of the things
we had to deal with,
they are still very much affecting
life in America and we still have
to deal with these issues.
>> Kevin Merida: You know recently,
we've seen protests certainly
in Charlotte and in
other places related
to police shootings
of African-Americans.
How do we get past the
tension that we're seeing here
in this country related
to that subject?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
Well, I think,
the only way that we can
get past the tension is
to acknowledge a few things that
historically we have not been able
to deal with because they're
very disturbing issues.
The fact that blacks and other
minorities are often dehumanized
in the eyes of the average
citizen, the average white citizen
and that stereotypes and
generalizations about people
of color, different factions of the
minority communities around here,
they don't really understand
them as people.
They see them as objects.
They see them as exotic creatures
but they don't see them as people
that have the same tendencies and
the same desires as anyone else.
They kind of see them
as exotic creatures.
Too often, black people
are seen as piece of burden
who now have become citizen.
Well, we were brought here to
pick cotton and work on farms.
We were not brought here to
participate in American society.
And once that happened, it created
a situation that we are still living
with and still having problems with.
>> Kevin Merida: You know there's
an interesting debate that seems
to have taken place now, at
least in the political sphere,
where there have been
these shootings, of course,
of unarmed black men and then
there's a whole other people saying,
"What about black-on-black crime?"
You addressed that, I just
want to read something briefly
which I thought was
really smart, you know.
And you said, "The current
card trick of politicians
and pundits is black-on-black
crime, which they use
to show the real problem
isn't white racism
but blacks attacking each other.
The not-so-subtle suggestion is
that black problems are
black society's own fault
because they can't
control their own people.
Black-on-black crime actually
makes the opposite point
because it's a by-product
of centuries
of interning blacks
in economic gulags."
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Exactly.
The fact that black Americans
cannot access the mainstream
of society means that they
are forced to desperation
and the only equal
opportunity employer
for desperate people is crime.
You don't have to have
any qualifications.
All you have to do is be
willing to do something illegal
and maybe you can make
a few bucks doing that.
And too often, blacks
and other minorities,
that's the only access they have
to making any money and
this is unfortunate.
It's a failure of the
educational system to prepare them
to participate legally
in our society.
It's also the effect
that the destruction
of the black family has had.
Black parents spend so much
time trying to keep a roof
over their family's heads
and food on their table
that they don't have time to
go to parent-teacher meetings
or help junior and little
miss with their homework.
And again, the educational system
fails these children and they end
up having kids too early and seeing
that crime is the only
way out for them.
And that this situation
repeats itself.
There's more or less a pipeline
from the public school
system to the present system.
This is very unfortunate and
very unnecessary but it's going
to take a supreme effort
to actually cure it
and eliminate it from our society.
>> Kevin Merida: You know, you,
you know, everybody knows you
as this great athlete,
you know, leading scorer.
I know some people have-- some
of your records have been broken
but that one hasn't been broken yet.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Right.
>> Kevin Merida: And--
But yet you've spent all
of these years really kind
of in the world of
the mind, you know.
I've been always struck by
your perspective as an athlete
and I can't really think of
many athletes who have that kind
of deep perspective on
the subjects of the day.
You talked about the issue of
class and inequality in your book
and specifically that, you
know, there was this passage
where you said, "If I
have been a foot shorter,
I might have been a history teacher,
trying to figure out at the end
of my career if I'm going to have
enough money and can I retire now."
When as a basketball player,
you know, in your last year,
people showered you with applause
and gifts and gratitude and all
of these appreciation and just
that sense of does everybody here
in this country have this
same shot at success.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well, that
is a very real issue and people
who don't have that shot at success
really have to struggle to figure
out how they're going
to make ends meet,
that this is a very commonplace
issue for too many people.
>> Kevin Merida: How
do we solve that?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well, I
think the only way to solve it is
to see to it that you cannot
make equality as something
that we champion and
something that we support.
There have been a number of
studies more recently that it show
that the increasing of the minimum
wage really has benefited a lot
of people and enable a lot
more families to do better.
And I think that's something that
really needs to continue to happen.
>> Kevin Merida: What do you think
about today's athletes and the role
that they play or should
play enforcing social change,
the kind of influence that they can
have we've certainly been having
this discussion ever since
Colin Kaepernick, you know,
first set out the national
anthem and then took a knee
and we've been debating the
role of athletes in influence.
What's your perspective on that?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well,
I think that professional
athletes have a great platform
to use especially if they
want to use it positively.
I remember when I was a kid,
so many of my heroes and people
that I look up to were athletes.
And in those days, they didn't
have anything to say politically.
But, you know, that's changed
and I think that doesn't have
to be a bad thing as long
as those athletes understand
that they have a responsibility,
they are role models, and whether
or not they've been listening
to Charles Barkley say
that he's not a role
model, that doesn't matter.
They have to understand that
they have a responsibility there.
But if they get that,
they can do a lot of good.
>> Kevin Merida: Who were the
athletes you admire the most today?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well,
I'd-- at the ESPN Awards,
I was really happy with what
Lebron and Carmelo, Chris Paul--
>> Kevin Merida: There must
be some frenzy ESPN out there.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Yeah.
And D-Wade, they got up on
stage and made a very poignant
and effective statement
and they were not--
they didn't do it in a
destructive or hostile manner.
I think that's the only way
that this platform can
be used effectively
because when people ignore what
the message is and just focus
on the fact that they had
a very hostile attitude
that that destroys the
effect of the message.
So I'm really was pleased
with what they did.
One of them, Dwayne Wade,
he just lost a cousin
to gun violence in Chicago.
>> Kevin Merida: Yeah.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
It's a real issue.
>> Kevin Merida: It was the
day after we had a Town Hall.
The Undefeated sponsored
a Town Hall and--
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Right.
>> Kevin Merida: --
he participated on.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Yeah.
>> Kevin Merida: And it was just
five minutes from that Town Hall.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Right.
Michael Jordan has become involved
after sitting out for so long.
He's decided to get involved.
He's donated money and spoken up.
Again, someone that a lot of
Americans admire and respect
and they'll listen to him.
So I think that this platform
can be a very useful tool
in helping change take place
by giving young people an idea
of what they can do and
the best way to do it.
>> Kevin Merida: You know, I kind of
wonder there's an iconic photograph
and this surfaced a lot
particularly after Ali died
of the Cleveland's Summit, and you
and Jim Brown and Bill Russell,
Bobby Mitchell and others
gathering around Ali.
This is after he'd
resisted the draft, 1967.
And everybody remembers
that scene, you know.
It was kind of a representation of
really prominent athletes gathering
around a prominent athlete.
I kind of wondered whether
we would see something
like that after Colin Kaepernick.
What are your thoughts,
prominent athletes gathering
around in a similar--
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well,
I think what Colin did really
has given a lot of the players
in the NFL an idea about
how to use their platform.
So you saw demonstrations
on a number
of NFL fields last
Sunday of the teams.
For example, the Seattle Seahawks,
they came out locked arm in arm,
black and white players showing
some solidarity and some--
and voicing their concerns.
So, you know, Colin's
example really--
has really served as a wake-up call
for a lot of professional athletes
to maybe think about doing
something of that nature that--
on issues that concern them and that
they feel needed to be discussed.
And I'm very happy
that that happened.
>> Kevin Merida: For the early
part of your life and that goes
up to college, people
knew you as Lew Alcindor,
and you write about
your conversion to Islam
and I thought maybe I would
just read a short passage.
You said, "The transition from Lew
to Kareem was not merely a change
in celebrity brand name, like
Sean Combs to Puff Daddy to Diddy
to P. Diddy, but a change
of heart, mind and soul.
Mine was not just a
simple conversion
but also a spiritual transformation.
I used to be Lew Alcindor,
pale reflection
of what white America
expected of me.
Now I'm Kareem Abdul-Jabbar,
the manifestation
of my African history,
culture and beliefs."
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Exactly.
[ Applause ]
>> Kevin Merida: What has been,
to carry that a little further
for the audience, what has been
the impact of that transition
for you to where you are now?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well, in
going through that transformation,
I felt that I assumed an
identity that was actually me
and that related to what I saw
was my history and my heritage
and my American heritage.
Muslims took part in
the Revolutionary War.
A lot of people don't understand
that because they don't have
accurate records but a lot
of the slaves that joined the
Revolutionary Army were Muslim.
And some of them gained
their freedom by fighting
in the Revolutionary War.
And also there were Muslims that
fought with the Camp Lafayette,
Moroccan Muslims that fought
with the French contingents
of soldiers that help win the war.
So, you know, Muslims
participated in America
from its very first inception.
The very first country to
recognize the United States
as a sovereign nation was
the Kingdom of Morocco,
and people don't realize that.
So, you know, Islam has had
an interaction with our nation
and Muslims had been part
of our nation from day one.
>> Kevin Merida: History,
you really love history.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Absolutely,
history is a great teacher.
If we don't-- what Mr. Santayana
said-- Mr. George Santayana said,
"Those who do not understand
history are condemned to repeat it."
And we'd made a lot of faux pas in
our historical efforts at times.
So, you know, we have to
pay attention to the--
to what we have done in the past
because we can use these
successful efforts as a template
and we can also use the unsuccessful
efforts as a warning not
to repeat those mistakes.
>> Kevin Merida: So,
you as a writer,
and certainly you write your books
but you write columns and some
of them are very provocative and
you become a journalist like me.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Yeah.
Well, I was a journalist
starting way back in 1964, right?
I actually worked on a newspaper--
community newspaper in Harlem
but I was between my
junior and senior year
in high school and I was writing.
>> Kevin Merida: And you also--
did you note on that end of it,
you said your Facebook
page is like a magnet--
a super magnet for racial
slurs, that there's a lot of--
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Oh yeah.
>> Kevin Merida: -- that
kind of feedback in.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Oh, I
get a lot of negative feedback
but if you're an author
and you express opinions
that people feel are controversial
or not exactly according
to their taste, they're going
to let you hear about it.
But I must say I get a
lot more positive feedback
than I do negative feedback.
[ Applause ]
>> Kevin Merida: What's
your next book?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: My next
book, my next book is going
to be a discussion of my 50-year
relationship with my high--
with my college coach, John Wooden.
We had a very long and
wonderful relationship
that lasted up until he died.
I was with him just three
hours before he passed away.
And I've known him since 1965
and it was a wonderful experience
and I'm going to share it.
The book is in the process
now of being written.
>> Kevin Merida: All right.
[ Applause ]
I think we want to go
to some questions now.
Do you have some line up
and Kareem will take them.
>> I'll start, OK.
You spoke that-- You say that if
you hadn't been still set foot to
or whatever, you've
been a foot shorter,
you may have been a teacher.
I think if you've been a foot
shorter with your intellect,
you might have been an All-Time
point guard doing great sort of.
But with that being said,
you mentioned earlier
about our school systems failing our
young people, what's your thoughts
on the chartered school systems?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well, I
think that the school systems here
in America had American high
school students number one
in all the really crucial
and important disciplines
that schools teach up
until somewhere in the '60s
and then we started to fade
away when people decided
that they did not want to spend the
money to support integrated schools.
And that's when the public
school system started to fail.
And we've got to get over that.
[ Applause ]
We have to get back to
where we spend the money.
There are so many great
teachers who don't teach
because they can't support
their families on the salaries
that they're offered and now
they're working for Google
and Microsoft and places like that.
[ Applause ]
So it's my sincere hope that the
school systems start paying the
teachers what they need to be paid
because they've done a great job
over so many years and
given us so many capable
and wonderful people coming
out and doing all the things
that people do here in
America because we have--
this is the land of opportunity.
So we got to get back to
that and not be afraid
to support these efforts
because they've been successful.
>> Thank you.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
Thank you for your question.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much for being here.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: My pleasure.
>> It's a real thrill,
at least for me.
You mentioned that you're
a student of history
and I would be really
intrigued you know who were some
of the history biography writers
that you admire and respect
and have been your
favorites over the years?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Oh
geez, that's a tough one for me
because I read so much, I don't
know where to start with that one.
Well, I'm sharing those
book on Alexander Hamilton,
who is probably the most
recent one that I've read
that really enlightened me and
helped me understand a lot more
about our nation and
how it was formed.
I go back to that one because it was
just-- it's was brilliantly written
and it really explained
so much about America.
I've read a really good
biography on Jefferson
and I'm forgetting the author's name
so you have to forgive me on that.
"The Autobiography of
Malcolm X" was a book
that really helped me understand
my place here in America
and it started me my
interest in Islam.
So those would be a couple
of books that I've read
about historical figures that really
have helped me and grow and learn.
>> Thank you.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
Thank you for your question.
>> Two questions.
First, are we going to get
another Mycroft Holmes novel?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Yes, we are
because my publishers begging me
to do another one so I got to work
on that one and I'm going to have
to wear a couple of hats to get
all these work done but yeah,
we're going to have to
do something about that.
>> OK. And then my second
question is with there being
such a rich tradition of
African-American detective novels,
when writing a detective novel, why
did you choose to base it on the--
like Sherlock and Mycroft Holmes
area of detective fiction?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well,
I really enjoyed Chester
Himes writings about Harlem
and the two detectives that he
wrote about in some of his works
but the very first detective
novel that I read was the
"Complete Works" of
Arthur Conan Doyle.
So I kind of started
on that and then I kind
of graduated to other things.
And I just felt that I
pay no much to Mr. Doyle
because he really started it all.
Well, actually Edgar
Allan Poe started all with
"The murders in the Rue Morgue".
But Arthur Conan Doyle
got on that train
and did a great job so that's why.
>> Thank you.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
You're welcome.
>> Yeah. I was just wondering
as a mother of teachers
and my son-in-law got
his PhD in Appalachian.
I began to read history books.
I'm a product, I graduated from high
school in 1964 and at that time,
I remembered elementary
school how I was thought
about the Emancipation Proclamation.
And then I read book
"Slavery by Another Name"
and I was very disturbed
with the misinformation
that was taught to me in my youth.
Because slavery did not end at
with the Emancipation Proclamation,
slavery didn't end
until the mid 1940s.
And I was just wondering,
how do you feel
about that the way we were taught
and what we were taught it was
slanted for the white history.
And the black history
was really taught
to us the way it should have been.
So, how do you feel about
that the misinformation
that was taught to us in our youth?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well,
I think that misinformation really
is based on just a reluctant
of Americans to call a spade
a spade because they would say
that once the American-- the
Emancipation Proclamation came
into effect the slavery ended.
Well, certain type of slavery ended
but after the civil
war black people--
black Americans were
arrested and incarcerated
and then made to work
on chain gangs.
And it was the same cheap labor that
had existed prior to the civil war.
But they're working as
convicts instead of slaves
but it was the same deal.
And that's when you referring to
that lasted up into the 1940s.
And then there's still
arraignment of that happening
and it's you don't do-- the way
that the school systems now just
channel kids to go from failing
at school to our present system.
That's still happening and there's
no more need for cheap laborer.
[ Applause ]
So, you know, it's the same thing.
They put a different mask on
it but it's the same phenomena
and it's something that
has to end on our country.
And I think that this type
of institutionalized racism is
something we have to let go of.
It's like a drug for our nation
that we just can't let go of.
We can't allow all of
the potential from all
of the different ethnic groups
in our country to blossom
until we get rid
of this institutionalized
racism and I hope we do that.
[ Applause ]
>> Hello, my name is
Brittany [assumed spelling].
You said that your inspiration
for writing this book was
because you felt like given
the national conversation
that we weren't actually having
conversations with to each other
that we're talking past each other.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Yes.
>> And I feel that in my group
there are a lot of people like me
who are very to willing to
have that conversation at first
and now I have a lot
of frustration and find
that my Facebook friend
count is significantly lower
that it used to be.
So, my question for you is
how do you recommend we have
that conversation and are there
some people and some situations
where the conversation
is not worth having?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well, I
would just tell you to be patient
and I would just remind
you that when we try
to form the constitution the various
factions from the various states
at times hated each other we
wouldn't talk to each other.
And they were totally frustrated
with the ignorance and lack
of awareness of some
of the other factions.
The people from Vermont
thought that the people
from South Carolina did not
know anything and vice versa
and that could have been said about
any of the different factions.
But finally, they got around
and talking to each other
and listening to each other.
And you have to be able to listen
and you have to be able to speak
with respect and patience
until the other side listens.
And if they don't want to let
go of the ideas that they have
that are destructive then
there's not much you can about it.
But it requires patience and it's
amazing how long it takes before
consensus is achieved but it's
somethings that's worth waiting for.
If we hadn't done it we would
not have this coordination
and the incredible document
that is called the United
States Constitution.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> It's a thrill to
see, it really is.
I have a lot of respect for
you as an athlete, you know,
growing up in the '80s and whatnot.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Thank you.
>> Recently they have the document--
the documentary about OJ
Simpson that was on there.
And you were talking about
sitting it out and we--
there are athletes out
there that at least me
as a fan I view it as
have sat out things.
And I guess my questions is in the
'60s as an athlete you're a brand
and speaking your mind can damage
that brand especially if you're,
you know, an athlete of color
and whatnot or at least it seems
like there is that possibility.
So, when you did joined up with the
other athletes in the late '60s,
early '70s and you spoke your mind.
Were there any costs to you as far
as that goes and what is the cost
to athletes who do set it out.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well, you
know, athletes who have the nerve
and the courage to speak out, their
brand is affected in so much is
that people who don't
appreciate their point
of view like not support them.
But also in addition to those people
you will get support from people
who realized that you actually
have said something meaningful.
So, you know, you lose on one end
but you also gain on another end.
I lost the line of access to
let's say commercial viability
because I was known as maybe being
a troublemaker or somebody who spoke
about issues that most
people found uncomfortable
and difficult to speak about.
But we have to speak
about these things.
Someone has to talk about them.
And if you're going to be able to
affect any change you have to take
that risk, you have to be
able to risk what's going on.
Muhammad Ali risked his career.
He lost three of his most productive
years where he could not fight
because he was stripped
of his title.
But what do you had to say about
the Vietnamese War became what our
country ended up standing
up for and the fact
that the Vietnamese War
was unjust and illegal
and we finally got
behind them on that issue.
So, it takes that.
[ Applause ]
Yeah.
>> Yeah, I believe it'd
be refreshing if some
of our elected officials showed
more intellectual prowess
in this relationship.
And I was wondering
whether you have other--
ever considered or would you
consider running for elected office?
Also--
[ Applause ]
Also, would you care to comment
on the current contest
going on for the president?
[ Laughter ]
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: I comment
regularly on that in my column
in the Washington Post,
so you could read that.
[ Laughter ]
And I think that we're coming
to a very crucial election here.
Americans are going to make
a decision about who's going
to lead their country and I
hope that they inform themselves
and vote their conscience in a
meaningful way and do what's best
for the country and not
what's good for partisan game.
I think if Americans are
really concerned about that
that they will do that and I
hope that's how it's works out.
>> Thank you sir and
I loved your game.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
Oh, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi, Kareem.
So, I go to school in the south
and I'm pretty visibly Muslim.
So, I was just wondering how do
you deal with day long when people
with not only questions about your
blackness and about how you deal
with racism but also
about your Muslim-ness
and how you deal with Islamophobia?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
Well, for me I just--
if people are interested I explain
to them what Islam is all about
and how its helped me, how is has
been a moral anchor in my life
and enable me to tell right
from wrong and how the Prophet--
one of the things that Prophet
Muhammad said was seek knowledge,
if you have to go from here
which was Arabia to China
which was the farthest
place away from Arabia
that the Arabs knew about.
So, we have to go to great
lengths to educate ourselves
and that's how Islam has
affected me and its enable me
to have a moral anchor that
have served me very well.
And that's all you have
to explain and your life
and your presence will speak all the
rest to people that they'll be able
to see what your worth
is and your value just
by the way you conduct yourself.
So just follow your moral compass
and I'm sure you're
going to end up being OK.
>> Thank you.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
You're welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> About 30 years ago, way back
when I saw you, I heard you speak
in Auburn University
in Auburn, Alabama.
I don't know if you remember way
back when [laughs], never mind.
But anyway, I asked a particular
question and I don't know
if you remember the question,
if you remember the experience
and I'm going to ask
the question again.
With you traveling around the
country and seeing certain kinds
of things over the
years and experiencing,
let say down in Atlanta, the
Sweet Auburn district in Atlanta,
the Black Wall Street in Chicago
and The Harlem Renaissance,
all of these experiences have
been diminished with the advent
of I would say once we
decided to integrate
into mainstream American society,
we lost a lot of those
historical values.
And what in your opinion is
the legacy of those districts
that we lost the Sweet Auburn
district, the Black Wall Street
and things of that nature?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well,
I think that those things
that you just referred to, you
know, Harlem and Sweet Auburn
and the Black Wall
Street, they were result
of the segregation of our society.
And now that our society has
partially enabled people of color
to succeed, those neighborhoods
have become abandoned and all
of the most successful people in
those neighborhoods have left.
So that's really what the decline
of those neighborhoods represents.
And I don't think we're going to
go back there until, you know,
unless and until Americans want
to re-segregate themselves.
I don't think that will happen.
>> OK.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: So I think
that's just a nostalgic thing.
I miss Harlem.
You know, I was born and--
>> Yeah.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
-- and raised there.
>> Right.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: And I
know what you're talking about.
>> Yeah.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: But
I think we have to move on.
>> Move on, that's right.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
Yes, and you're welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Yes.
>> A few months ago in June,
the Supreme Court heard a case
called the, "Fisher Versus Texas"
which had the potential to end
the affirmative action policies
in this country.
But by a mere one vote margin, they
upheld the constitutionality of it.
So affirmative action
is allowed to continue.
What are your thoughts
on this decision?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
Well, I think that some type
of affirmative action is necessary
to heal some of the wounds
that have been inflicted on
people of color in this country.
It doesn't necessarily
have to come at the expense
of denying other people
opportunities.
But I think the affirmative action
in this country should
be an educational effort
in poor communities, especially
poor communities of color where lack
of educational opportunity
really is something
that is damaging those communities
and does not allow them to thrive.
So, you know, we can't hold people
who are alive today responsible
for things that happen
50 and 150 years ago.
That's why I've never been
an advocate for reparations
but we can educate the people
who are the survivors of that,
who are the descendants of people
who were victimized in those times.
We can get them up to
speed educationally
so that they can participate
in the American society
and raise their families
and do the good things
that they have the potential to do.
[ Applause ]
>> Yes.
>> Hello my name is Ran
Allen [assumed spelling]
and I'm a freshman
Sports Medicine major
at Howard University,
minor in Journalism.
And I read earlier or what the
years ago about how you said
that basketball was more
of a hobby and writing was
like what you were really passionate
about and that was your career.
And that's something that I'm
really interested in as well,
and so in doing that I
watch a lot of sports shows.
And I was watching the podcast of
Undisputed where Skip Bayless said,
he spoke about major league
baseball player Steve Clevenger.
And he said that he felt he
hated the fact that he had
to share the same skin tone as
him because of his comments,
the Twitter comments he made
yesterday or two days ago.
And I was going to
asks you, isn't that--
this question isn't about
how to feel about those
who say the wrong things but
about the people like Skip
who actually understand that
what is being said is wrong.
What was going on the
situation is wrong
but they aren't the
ones experiencing.
So I was asking you, how important
do you think it is for those
who are not African-American
to speak out and be more bold
about the injustice
that is going on around?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well,
I think that what you have
to understand is that
injustice affects us all.
And you don't have to worry
about the color of the people
who are ignorant about that.
So if you are-- if you understand
something, you have an obligation
to educate that person or
let them go on and continue
to be ignorant and destructive.
So that's on you as an individual to
impart that knowledge that enables
that person to correct their
course and start talking
about things that do make sense.
So that's on you.
That's on you as an individual
and you ask someone who cares.
If you care about these
issues, you have to speak out.
And don't worry about the color
of the people that you talk
to because we're all
neighbors here whether--
whatever color that you are.
The people around you are your
neighbors and fellow citizens
and someone will need
to be educated.
So you have to take that
person with responsibility
and accept the consequences
and, you know,
if you don't get your
point across, you did try.
And that's all you can do.
>> Yes sir.
Do you mind if I ask
one follow up question?
[ Applause ]
>> Could I ask my follow
up question?
The national-- I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
The National African-American
Museum, the new one opened up today
and it's-- Matisse have
talked about it and I said
that it starts basically
with African-American slavery
and into the modern era but
everyone knows and understands
that African-American
history begins before slavery.
And we see-- I see the museum
as more of trying to stick
to the political stigma of
museums as far as educating about.
You start with what we think is the
worst into something that is good,
but we don't understand the
things or respect the fact
that there was more or
better things that were part
of African-American
culture before slavery.
So I was going to ask you, what
do you think of the significance
of the museum or do you believe that
there should be more added to it?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well,
you know, I haven't had a chance
to check the museum out, so
I don't know what's in there.
>> Yeah.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
But just the fact
that they have an African-American
museum, if there are problems
with it that they can be fixed.
That is a common thing, well, with
museums and any place that deals
in public education like that.
So whatever is going on over
there, it can be fixed eventually
and if you find something wrong
with it make sure you go down there
and let your voice be heard.
>> Yes sir, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Yeah, in a recent conversational
in race, someone mentioned to me
that they felt with the election
of Obama, certain forms of racism
that were maybe covert
that people wouldn't talk
about were more vocal
on their opinions.
And that kind of resonated
with me when I thought about it
and I didn't know if
what you thought
on that statement and
the impact of that.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well, it
should be obvious, turning body look
at all the opposition
President Obama has had to deal
with trying to get things done.
Look at how much he
could have gotten done.
[ Applause ]
Look at all the things that
he could have gotten done
if he had not been opposed at every
turn by the Republicans in Congress.
They really don't like him.
They called him a liar
while he was trying
to address the combined
members of the House
of Representatives and the Senate.
It's been pretty obvious
that they resent the fact
that a black man whipped them twice.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And I think our country has
suffered because of that resentment
and the way that they tried to speak
around the issue that, you know,
he has some good ideas and
they wouldn't work with him
so they decided they
would work against him.
It's very unfortunate but
that's what we're dealing with.
We're going to have to
shut this down pretty soon,
so I'm going to take
four more questions.
And then we'll going
to have to move on.
I hope you can forgive me but we
do have time concerns here, OK?
So we'll do four more questions.
Yes.
>> Hello, my name is Erreo
Adams [assumed spelling].
I'm a freshmen legal communications
major at Howard University.
And I just wanted to ask, I have
three siblings, they're all younger
than me and two of them are my
brothers and I don't know how
to get them to understand
what's going on in the world
because like you said,
they're products
of the public schooling
system in the south.
So they don't know what's going
on or they don't understand it
and they really have no motivation
to educate themselves about it.
And I don't know how to get
them to see it without--
I don't know like slamming
it in their face.
So how do I, you know, just
explain to them and get them
to have some motivation
about doing better?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: That's
a very difficult thing for me
to answer because I don't
know them personally.
And you make me-- you've reminded me
of this statement that
ignorance is bliss.
That's a very unfortunate
thing for your brothers.
So there has to be some way
that you can point out to them
through practical and obvious
examples how ignorant they are
and how that ignorance
is hurting them.
That's the only way
that you can do that.
And it's going to take
an effort on your part.
I don't know the specifics
in your family,
so I'm not trying to generalize it.
But it's going to take a
significant effort on your part.
But I'm glad you care about them.
I have written-- the very
first book that I wrote
after I finished my basketball
career that had nothing to do
with basketball is called,
"Black Profiles in Courage"
and it is an overview of
African-American history.
And I think by putting some
knowledge in front of them
that they can relate to, that might
help them broaden their perspective
and get a better idea on things.
So just, you're going to have
to put some books in the hands
and from what you describe,
they probably don't read or--
>> I know [laughs].
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: -- some-- a
lot of people who are very hostile
to education sometimes are dyslexic
and maybe you might want to check
that issue out with them also
because that affects
a lot of people.
You'd be surprised how many people
who are jailed are dyslexic people
who are angry about the fact that
they couldn't learn in school.
So that might be an issue
but good luck with that.
And I hope that you
get some success there.
>> OK, thank you.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
You're welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Yes.
>> I'm Anaya Harrison
[assumed spelling].
I was in the elevator
with you, but [laughs].
My question is what would you say
to young African-American teenagers
like myself trying to
navigate in a world
where innocent black
people are being shot
and there are still a
lot of racism going on?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well, I--
the thing I tell all
young people regardless
of race is that knowledge is power.
So do the best you can to get the
most thorough and complete education
that you can in whatever field
that you feel is appropriate
for you whatever your taste
dictate on that issue.
And just go out in the world and
do the best you can within the area
that you have some reach at.
So the people that you encounter
and your friendly members
or all the people that you
work with or hangout with.
Make sure that you spread that
light because knowledge is power.
And just accumulate all
the power that you can
and share it with the world.
>> OK.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: OK?
>> Thank you.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
You're welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Yes.
>> Yes, my name is Susan Shapiro.
Thank you very much
for speaking today.
I am presently writing a book with
a law enforcement agent to try
to change the mentality
of police officers.
And we want to get into a real--
the elephant in the
room and I was wondering
if you could give some
advice on what is the core
of the-- what we need to teach.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well,
I think the elephant is--
in the room is the way that
they have stereotype people
of color especially black
Americans as being prone
to criminality and ignorant.
And in addition to being
ignorant, being stupid,
and unable to learn anything it's
a process that dehumanizes people
of color and the police force think
that they're not dealing with people
but they're dealing with animals
and that brute force is usually
the easiest and most effective way
of dealing with people of color.
You have to get it-- get them to
the point where they understand
that these are people, people who
have been victimized by the dictates
of our society that have been so
prevalent for over two decades--
for over two centuries now.
Until they understand that and have
some compassion, they will continue
to treat them like they are animals
that need to be rudely let around.
>> But this one law
enforcement agent is determined
and he has the access to get it
into the schools and he is going
to be hopefully be a spokesperson
for this, so thank you very much.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
You're welcome.
Good luck.
[ Applause ]
>> Kevin Merida: You only
got time for one more.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
We're only going to have time
for two more questions, so.
Yes.
>> Which do you like better,
basketball or writing books?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
Oh, that's very easy.
Right now I like writing
books because I'm in no shape
to play basketball anymore.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And if I write books I get
people like you comment
and they ask me questions and
some of them read my books,
so I'm very flattered that
you asked that question
and I hope you read
one or two of my books.
[ Applause ]
>> Karrem, thank you so
much for coming today
and for contributing your voice to
these very important conversations.
It seems to me that our
society and the world
at large these times are becoming
more divisive and very vitriolic.
And what I was wondering
is how do we do better
because there are people even on
the progressive side of the aisle
who claim to be for unity but
who seem on insight divisiveness.
And it's easy to point the
finger at the other side
but what can we do better as
individuals and as a movement
and as a society to close
that gap and to become better?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: Well,
my hope issue on that is just
have some compassion of people
who are just locked in to
their own point of view.
It takes a greater effort
to get through to them
because they don't want to
hear anything else and you have
to be patient enough and persistent
enough to get through that wall
that be put up around their point
of view and they're going to hold
on to it no matter how much
evidence that they have
that that point of
view does not work.
So you have to have the
patience and the determination
to work your way through there.
And it takes time and sometimes it
doesn't happen but whoever that is
that you're referring to I
hope you get through to them.
Because it's really having a bad
effect on our country and we got
to do something about that.
>> Right. I mean-- I'm sorry.
I was more referring to like we like
a unifying voice in our generation
like a Dr. King, a voice
for peace and a voice
that brings people together.
And it seems like most of our
national dialog is around who is
at fault and how can we point
the finger at the other side
and how do we get back
to that unifying voice
and how do we get back to that one
nation standing together against,
you know, the evils of the world
instead of one nation standing
in divisiveness against itself.
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar:
Well, you know,
Dr. King wasn't always
a unifying voice.
Dr. King offended a lot of people.
[ Applause ]
But the people that Dr. King
offended were trying to hold
on to points of view that were
very detrimental to our nation
and you just have to be
able to break through that.
That's all it is.
It takes time and it
takes repeated effort.
But we can get there.
We would not be here at
this point, so if you look
out in the audience it's a rainbow
and we wouldn't be at this point.
When our nation was founded it was
for white males that own property.
Women weren't allowed.
People of color weren't allowed.
And it was only about white
people who had owned land.
So, we've gotten a great distance.
We have a great distance
to go but we can get there.
It's just going to take patience.
This is-- Are we done here?
Pause, another short
person there, all right.
[ Laughter ]
How you doing?
>> What is your favorite
part about writing?
>> Kareem Abdul-Jabbar: My
favorite part about writing is
when I get the book finished.
It's--
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
It takes a lot of effort
to write a book
and when you finally get finished
it's like you've had a baby.
But this baby can live a much
longer than the average baby
and hopefully people will read
it and be motivated by it.
So thank you for your questions.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.